australien brennt die gletscher
schmelzen die wälder verloren die böden
sind hart und trocken
wir kennen die bilder dennoch
unternehmen wie er wenig chancen
mit dem ich gleich sprechen glaubt wir
müssen die geschichte einfach anders und
besser erzählen
und wer sollte das können wenn nicht er
er ist einer der wichtigsten
schriftsteller der usa und hat 2010 auch
bei uns die besten listen gestürmt mit
seinem sachbuch tiere essen einer
radikalen kritik an der
massentierhaltung in seinem neuesten
buch wir sind das klima knüpfte sich
nichts geringeres vor als die rettung
der welt herzlich willkommen schon ist
in sachen vor
ja die welt retten ein großes ziel ging
es nicht ein bisschen kleiner
das ziel über das ich schreibe ist etwas
kleiner
der titel ist sehr groß aber der inhalt
des buchs ist bescheiden ich schrieb es
weil ich etwas spürte dass viele
menschen spüren nämlich ein bewusstsein
von dem was passiert die absolute
gewissheit dass sich die erde wie uns
die wissenschaftler sagen erwärmt und
das wissen welche unsere aktivitäten die
erde aufheizen und obwohl ich das weiß
und deswegen besorgt bin obwohl ich
ständig darüber rede an die nation mit
freunden mit meinen kindern oder sogar
mit mir selber trotz alldem lebte ich
ein leben das meine wertvorstellungen
nicht zu wie der spiegel erschienen ich
meine nicht ein leben in dem man den
planeten auf irgend eine heroische weise
rettet oder zerstört sondern in den
kleinen persönlichen entscheidungen die
wir ständig treffen nämlich das auto
oder das fahrrad reise ich mit dem
flugzeug oder mit dem zug
was esse ich wollte also darüber
nachdenken und zwar nicht als
wissenschaftler oder journalist sondern
als individuum das ein hektisches leben
führt und das richtige tun
in washington und wir machen einen
kleinen spoiler was sozusagen dabei
herauskommt man muss ja ein buch ein
bisschen warten man muss lesen die seit
78 bis sie sagen worum es ihnen
eigentlich geht oder was sie empfehlen
um die welt zu retten sage ich jetzt
trotzdem sie sagen wir sollten
verzichten auf den konsum von tierischen
produkten also eigentlich vegan leben
bis zum abendessen also bis zum
abendessen darauf achten nachher können
wir eigentlich tun was wir wollen ist
das nicht ein ist ehrlich sagen sogar
ziemlich vorsichtig ich mein abends kann
ich dann essen was ich will ist
vielleicht gar nicht so schwierig zuerst
ist mir wichtig klarzustellen dass es
nicht einfach meine meinung ist es nicht
meine argumentation und auch nicht meine
sichtweise
es sind viel mehr wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse und sie sind überhaupt
nicht umstritten
lesen sie auch nur ein paar minuten auf
ihrem laptop oder handy die berichte der
uno oder des weltklimarats sowieso
ziemlich alle wissenschaftlichen studien
über den klimawandel im internet dann
sehen sie es herrscht ein sehr breiter
konsens darüber dass vier dinge die wir
persönlich tun viel stärker ins gewicht
fallen als alles andere
nämlich weniger zu fliegen ohne auto zu
leben weniger tierische produkte zu
essen und weniger kinder zu haben
eine der herausforderungen ist dass wir
alle diese dinge lieben könnten wir die
klimakrise lösen indem wir einfach
aufhören uns mit messern zu verletzen
hätten wir das schon längst gemacht aber
es ist sehr angenehm zu fliegen und die
welt zu sehen viele sind sehr gern
eltern und essen gern leckere gerichte
wir wissen tierische produkte gehören zu
den nahrungsmitteln welche die umwelt am
meisten schädigen
sie produzieren mehr
treibhausgasemissionen als alles andere
in der welt zusammen
wir wissen auch wie viel wir reduzieren
müssen
dazu müssen wir nicht ganz auf tierische
produkte verzichten und alle veganer
werden
die umfassendste analyse über die
beziehung zwischen nahrungsmitteln und
umwelt wurde ende 2008 10 veröffentlicht
darin heißt es menschen die in ärmeren
ländern leben also in teilen afrikas und
asiens können etwas mehr fleisch und
milchprodukte essen europäer und
bewohner die usa müssen ihren
fleischkonsum um etwa 90 prozent
reduzieren und rund 60 prozent weniger
milchprodukte essen und zu verhindern
was die autoren als katastrophale
irreversibler klimakatastrophe
bezeichnen da gibt es ja auch
unterschiedliche zahlen wie groß der
beitrag der nutztierhaltung insgesamt
eigentlich ist auf diese frage der
treibhausgasemissionen also der frage
auch wie sehr wie schnell der
klimawandel voran gehen wird sie nennen
das diskutieren das ja sehr ausführlich
dieses buch ist obwohl es von einem
schriftsteller geschrieben ist ein sehr
sachlich kundige buch mit ganz vielen
wissenschaftlichen daten auch und die
beiden zahlen die herumgeistern sind 14
5 prozent das ist die zahl die die fau
also der die welt
welternährungsorganisation dafür
plädiert ist die eine zahl die andere
zahl ist 51
die zahl des worldwatch instituts und
sie sagen ganz klar wir sollten die
höhere zahl nehmen weil nämlich die
tiefere zwar ganz wieder dinge nicht mit
einberechnet die das fleisch essen oder
das milchtrinken eben auch mit sich
bringen
richtig unter anderem sind die zahlen so
unterschiedlich wegen der faktoren die
sie berücksichtigen oder nicht
berücksichtigen
zum beispiel gehen 91 prozent der
abholzung des amazonas auf die haltung
von nutztieren zurück sei es zur
gewinnung von weideland oder von
anbauflächen für futterpflanzen wir
wissen wenn wir den amazonas abbrennen
setzen die brennenden räume viel co2
frei wir können aber auch mit
einbeziehen dass die bäume wenn man sie
hätte stehen lassen viel co2 absorbiert
hätten das berücksichtigt die 14,5
prozent zahl nicht die 51% zahl hingegen
schon
doch wenn man über diesen unterschied
diskutiert so groß er auch ist redet man
am wesentlichen vorbei
denn ob es nun 14 ein halb oder 51
prozent sind jeder wissenschaftler
anerkennt was der weltklimarat in seinem
letzten bericht schrieb wir können die
ziele des pariser klimaabkommens nicht
erreichen auch wenn wir alle lichter
ausschalten und morgen aufhören zu
fliegen und auto zu fahren
wir können diese ziele nicht erreichen
ohne den konsum von tierischen produkten
zu reduzieren
diesem thema auseinandersetzen
sie haben vorhin vier punkte genannt bei
dem wir individuell ansetzen können wir
uns aber eben auch die frage weniger
kinder zu bekommen
sie selber sind ja auch vater von zwei
kindern sie haben zwei söhne
nun gab es da ja auch an einigen aufruhr
nämlich um eine zahl des club of rome
die gesagt haben es sind tatsächlich 58
6 tonnen co2 die wir einsparen würden
pro kind das wir nicht bekommen während
dessen sie sagen mit der ernährung die
sie vorschlagen sparen die 1,3 tonnen
co2 dann merkt man eigentlich wäre das
beste doch wirklich keine kinder mehr zu
bekommen
wir müssen alle diese probleme lösen
sonst bleibt uns keine hoffnung
es bringt nichts abzuwägen was besser
ist keine kinder zu haben oder weniger
fleisch zu essen weniger zu fliegen oder
solaranlagen zu installieren oder ein
elektroauto zu kaufen
klimawandel ist ein globales sehr
vielschichtiges und kompliziertes
problem und die lösungen müssen
entsprechend global und vielschichtig
sein
jede sucht nach der patentlösung wenn
wir das tun können wir den planeten
retten
die realität ist wir werden den planeten
weder retten noch verlieren
wir stehen am anfang eines verlust
prozesses wir werden vieles verlieren
zum beispiel einige küstenstädte wie
venedig und meier wir werden teile des
amazonas
wir werden menschen leben verlieren
durch buschbrände dürren und krankheiten
unsere lebenserwartung wird sinken die
frage ist wie viel verlust können wir
verkraften
und das bestimmt wie viel veränderung
wir verkraften können
wenn wir also die überbevölkerung in den
griff
kommen und unsere ernährung anpassen
können wir den verlust teilweise
verringern
doch es ist verführerisch das ganze zu
vereinfachen und zu sagen wenn wir nur
dieses eine tun würden während es
tatsächlich sehr kompliziert ist
das ist nicht nur die frage dass sie es
nicht vereinfachen sollen sondern auch
die frage dass wir schnell in seine
schwarze peter spiel hinein kommen dass
wir sagen eigentlich geht es doch darum
kein fleisch mehr zu essen naja
eigentlich geht es ums fliegen
eigentlich geht es uns kinder haben
eigentlich geht es um die währung
bitcoin sie so viel strom braucht
eigentlich geht es um zu viele kleider
die wir kaufen
und die beginnen dauernd sozusagen das
problem zu verschieden und uns auch ein
bisschen zu beruhigen weil wir denken so
wirklich viel kann ich gar nicht tun
weil es gibt ja noch viel größere
probleme ich pflichte ihnen voll und
ganz bei und dieses buch ist nicht
unbedingt ein wissenschaftliches oder
journalistisches buch es ist auch kein
roman und es basiert primär auf
psychologie
es geht darum wie wir all unsere gefühle
ordnen können und wie diese unsere
entscheidungen beeinflussen
40 gab es eine umfrage in den usa laut
dem mehr als die hälfte aller teenager
angst hat und wütend ist
ich denke die meisten erwachsenen haben
die gleichen gemischten gefühle
neben vielen anderen empfindungen
pessimismus zeitweise dann wieder eine
art von optimismus frustration
traurigkeit und entschlossenheit zu
einer lösung beizutragen
dieser gefühls mix kann uns in zwei sehr
verschiedene richtungen führen
die eine ist eine zu starke
vereinfachung und eine art
verteidigungshaltung wir reden uns ein
wir seien nicht schuld an den problemen
und beschuldigen vielleicht gleichzeitig
andere sie würden sich nicht genug
einsetzen oder wir blenden das aus und
sagen ich bin ein mensch ich esse gerne
fleisch ich reise gern ich liebe meine
kinder ich will kinder haben
ich werde bestimmt nicht so eine art
ethischem roboter
aber in den gegebenheiten die mein leben
als mensch ausmachen möchte ich so viel
tun die ich kann vielleicht ist mein
beitrag kleiner als der von anderen
vielleicht ist er größer aber das muss
mich nicht kümmern
ein anfang ist immer hinzuschauen was
für mich möglich ist wie kann ich am
besten auf diese wissenschaftlichen
befunde reagieren
über diese gefühle die wir haben können
angesichts der sagen wir jetzt mal
drohenden katastrophe möchte ich später
noch mit ihnen sprechen weil ich glaube
das ist ganz zentrales thema was mich
manchmal endet ich habe gemerkt ich habe
das buch mit großer faszination gelesen
hab gedacht okay so einfach wäre es
eigentlich und dann müsste ich ja auch
gar nicht so viel tun und genau dass ich
das entlastende aber dann habe ich auch
ein interview gelesen im tages anzeiger
kürzlich mit dem lebensmittelhandel
händler christian jörg ein schweizer der
in saudi arabien bei der staatlichen
ernährungs mittel für vorsorge im
arbeitet und er sagt wir stehen vor
einem gigantischen fleisch boom weil
fleischkonsum korreliert mit reichtum
mit vermögen und viele große nationen
china beispielsweise oder überhaupt der
kontinent afrika die menschen werden
reicher und reicher und werden mehr und
mehr fleisch konsumieren und bass hat
etwas deprimierendes des theaters ist
deprimierend sie haben recht und es
stimmt aber es gibt zwei kräfte die in
entgegengesetzte richtungen ziehen die
eine ist der wohlstand die andere das
pflichtbewusstsein zum wohlstand
die menschen essen fleisch großenteils
weil es erfolg symbolisiert weil es
macht symbolisiert gut möglich dass sich
solche statussymbole veränderung
bestimmt unter jungen menschen an allen
us universitäten zusammen genommen gibt
es mehr vegetarier als katholiken für
junge menschen für teenager symbolisiert
also fleisch nicht wohlstand und erfolg
es steht für verschwendung materialismus
und umweltzerstörung
ich hoffe daher dass sich die kultur
weiterhin so schnell verändert wie jetzt
und das reiche leute nicht mehr sagen
ich brauche ein steak zum abendessen
sondern andere wege finden um sich gut
zu fühlen oder ihren wohlstand aus zu
als zweites würde ich sagen einige der
länder die sie erwähnt haben sind an
vorderster front bezüglich der reduktion
des fleischkonsums sowie china also das
größte land der welt mit einer
nationalen initiative den fleischkonsum
im kommenden jahrzehnt landesweit um die
hälfte reduzieren
2030 soll in china aus ökologischen
gründen halb so viel fleisch gegessen
werden wie heute deshalb hat die
regierung alle möglichen filmstars und
regisseure aus den usa und der ganzen
welt ins land geholt die in werbespots
den chinesen sagen wir müssen weniger
fleisch essen um den planeten zu retten
es gibt also gründe optimistisch zu sein
und gründe sehr besorgt zu sein wie sehr
braucht es das individuum bisher braucht
es meinen beitragen die sehr brauchen
wir die politik oder eine systemische
lösung so zu sagen dass ein vorwurf der
ihnen manchmal gemacht worden ist dass
man gesagt hat wir brauchen eigentlich
politische lösungen warum appellieren
sie nicht die legislative an die uno an
die behörden an die steuerbehörden warum
schreiben sie ein buch für das
individuum nun wir brauchen beides
individuen können die klimakrise nicht
lösen können aber wir können sie auch
nicht ohne die individuen lösen die art
von entscheidungen über die ich schreibe
fliegen essen auto fahren und weniger
kinder haben haben tiefgreifende
messbare auswirkungen auf das klima das
stimmt auch dass die messbare
auswirkungen auf die kultur haben auf
unternehmen und politiker so gab es vor
etwa einem jahr als ich dieses buch
schrieb in den usa meines wissens kein
fast food restaurant das veggie burger
im angebot hatte man bekam sie nirgendwo
wenn ich also wie ich das oft tat von
new york nach washington dc vor wo meine
eltern leben
bei einem burger king stoppte gab es
nichts vegetarisches zu essen
heute hat jedes fast food restaurant in
amerika einen weltbürger die us-firmen
beyond match oder impossible foods im
angebot
die fleischersatz hersteller beyond
mitch hatte den größten börsengang
überhaupt in den usa in den nächsten 20
jahren
und sie bieten diese produkte nicht an
weil die regierung sie dazu verpflichtet
und auch nicht weil dieses gute menschen
sind sondern weil die konsumenten sagen
das wollen wir wenn wir etwas wollen
verändert das den markt und wenn sich
der markt verändert ist es einfacher für
uns eine gute wahl zu treffen
dann treffen wir öfter eine gute wahl
und wenn wir das tun verändern sich die
unternehmen noch mehr und den
gewohnheiten folgen neue gesetze das
gleiche gilt für elektroautos tesla ist
hat kurzem die größte autofirma in der
us geschichte und zwar nicht weil die
regierung die herstellung von
elektroautos verlangte sondern wegen der
nachfrage der einzelne konsument hat ja
auch eine macht und die politik die
könnte nachziehen ernst fehr ein
berühmter schweizer ökonomie hat
kürzlich gesagt er wäre auch für eine
steuer auf alle produkte und zwar eine
steuer die proportional zum ausdruck
bringt wie groß der beitrag geben ist
zum klimawandel und dann könnte man
quasi umverteilen man verteuert die
produkte die schädlich sind für die
umwelt künstlich und man nimmt geld ein
mann könnte das geld sogar umverteilen
an die bevölkerung hätte also zugleich
auch noch einen eine art eine
umverteilung innerhalb der bevölkerung
das wäre eine idee die sie
wahrscheinlich sogar unterschreiben
werden sie würden einfach sagen das ist
nicht das worum es mir gegen buch das
würde ich auf jeden fall unterstützen
aber ich würde es anders beschreiben sie
sprachen von der idee produkte die der
umwelt schaden künstlich zu verteuern
ich würde sagen hören wir auf sie
künstlich zu verbilligen
wenn ein bürger umwelt kosten verursacht
muss jemand dafür bezahlen auch wenn wir
es nicht beim kauf tun jemand bezahlt
dafür
laut der uno gehört die
landwirtschaftliche tierhaltung zu den
zwei oder drei schlimmsten ursachen
jedes gravierenden umweltprobleme wie
die luftverschmutzung
gewässerverschmutzung verlust von
artenvielfalt oder abholzen
er bezahlt dafür wenn all das passiert
wir und später unsere kinder oder enkel
deshalb schlage ich vor ein burger soll
so viel kosten die ihr wirklich kostet
autos und flugreisen sollen so viel
kosten wie sie wirklich kosten kostet
ein flugticket von europa in die usa
plötzlich 15.000 dollar so viel kostet
es uns nämlich tatsächlich und wir
deshalb weniger fliegen ist dass die
freie markt es ist keine zumutung wie
gewisse leute sagen
man legt nicht einen künstlichen preis
fest um uns etwas wegzunehmen
vielmehr wurden gewisse preise künstlich
gesenkt was uns zu einer schlechten wahl
verleitet und dafür müssen unsere kinder
und enkel bezahlen
auch ganz oft in ihrem buch so oder auch
wenn man sie sonst liest das gefühl dass
sie dafür plädieren perspektiven zu
ändern neu zu sehen es gibt ein bilder
in ihrem buch das immer wieder auftaucht
nämlich das bild der erde von außen
gesehen wo sie quasi sagen der erste
mann auf dem mond hat diesen monat
gemacht diesen moment in dem man die
welt von außen gesehen hat und dieser
perspektivenwechsel der ist immer wieder
der moment in dem wir dinge ganz neu
sehen und vielleicht auch fast schon auf
neue gedanken kommen etwa 500 menschen
haben bisher die erde als kugel vom all
aus gesehen und ihre erfahrung war so
übereinstimmend dass man ihr einen namen
gab
aber wie effekt das ist ein gefühl
tiefer ergriffenheit sieht man die erde
vom all aus wird einem so seltsam das
klingt plötzlich bewusst dass wir auf
einem planeten leben das vergisst man so
leicht obwohl es offensichtlich ja nicht
sein könnte wir leben auf einem planeten
und wenn astronauten diesen planeten aus
distanz sehen wird ihnen bewusst wie
fragil er ist dass er von scheinbar
unendlicher schwarzer lehre umgeben
unser einziges zu hause ist und dass
wegen beschützen müssen diese
perspektive hat die astronauten
verändert viele engagierten sich nach
ihrer rückkehr für soziale projekte oder
wandten sich die spiritualität zu
ich werde die erde wohl nie aus dem all
sehen sie auch nicht
vermutlich aber wir haben unsere
persönlichen overview effekt momente ich
erlebe das manchmal an silvester
manchmal an meinem geburtstagen an den
geburtstag meiner kinder
wenn ein geliebter mensch stirbt diese
momente in denen ich zurückblicke und
mir bewusst wird wie kostbar das leben
ist und dass wir behutsam damit umgehen
müssen zum teil auch geschrieben am
sterbebett ihrer eigenen großmutter ihre
großmutter die 1941 aus einem städte
geflohen ist das 20-jährige familie
wurde danach umgebracht um diese momente
in denen sie mit der schreibmaschine
oder ihren notizbüchern an diesem bett
sitzen die scheinen sie sehr geprägt zu
haben war das tier sie auch sein
overview effekt ganz klar zu sehen wie
sie ich mache mir keine vorwürfe weil
und schäme mich nicht zuzugeben dass sie
fast die ganze zeit ignoriert so ist das
leben
meist ignoriert man die menschen die man
liebt die menschen die sich um einen
kümmern
vor allem die eltern oder großeltern die
etwas älter sind
meine großmutter gehörte für mich die
meiste zeit fast zum inventar
aber ich war jung und wollte andere
dinge tun draußen mit dem ball spielen
oder mit meinen freunden rumhängen
warum sollte ich mich zu einer 80 90 am
schluss fast 100 jährigen frau setzen
und solche gespräche führen
aber als ich bei ihr saß als es zu ende
ging sah ich sie völlig anders ich
realisierte was für opfer sie gebracht
hatten
wie mutig sie war sie ist der grund
warum meine familie überhaupt existiert
ihre geschwister wurden getötet ihre
eltern und großeltern wurden getötet und
auch alle ihre freunde sie hat als
einzige ihrer familie den krieg überlebt
das wusste ich immer aber ich bin nicht
sicher ob ich das auch immer gefühlt
habe
und ein großer teil dieses buch handelt
vom unterschied zwischen den dingen die
wir im kopf wissen und den dingen die
wir im herzen wissen und wie schwierig
es ist die dinge von da oben nach unten
zu bringen
diese bewegung von oben nach unten vom
denken vielleicht auch ins fühlen das
ist sozusagen das grundmotiv das
grundanliegen auch des buches haben sie
sehr schön beschrieben wie wir alle
diese over you moment wir haben in denen
uns das passiert dann kann es auch
herstellen durch gute geschichten durch
das erzählen von guten geschichten und
ich habe schon gesagt wer könnte das
denn nicht sie weil sie ein
schriftsteller sind fielen sie auch eine
spezielle verantwortung als
schriftsteller eben solche bücher auch
zu schreiben nicht nur romane ist und
man sich hinzusetzen und zu sagen ich
versuche eine geschichte zu erzählen die
die leute aufrüttelt und sie zum handeln
bringt ich fühle wahrscheinlich eine
ähnliche verantwortung wie sie sie haben
mich eingeladen um über dieses thema zu
sprechen obwohl viele gäste über themen
sprechen könnten die vier sexy lustige
oder attraktiver sind für die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer aber etwas
in diesem buch hat ihnen gesagt das ist
wichtig darüber müssen wir reden
an einer lesung kürzlich in london gab
es wie üblich eine fragerunde am ende
die letzte frage stellte ein
achtjähriges mädchen
sie saß in der ersten reihe und fragte
mich denken sie dass wir dieses problem
lösen werden wir den planeten retten
ich sag dir die wahrheit nämlich dass
ich es nicht weiß und fragte zurück
denkst du wie retten und sie sagte ich
weiß nicht ob sie es rechtzeitig
schaffen und ich was meinst du was
braucht es damit wir es rechtzeitig
schaffen sie sagte wir müssten ständig
darüber reden zu schreiben ist für mich
eine art über dinge zu reden nicht nur
mit leserschaft sondern auch mit mir
selbst etwas zu ergründen ist für mich
die beste
möglichkeit achtsam und sorgfältig mit
den stoffen umzugehen die mir wichtig
sind
egal ob es ein roman oder ein sachbuch
ist auch das hier ist eine art darüber
zu reden
ich bin total überzeugt von dem was das
mädchen sagt die klimakrise braucht
technologie sie braucht geld politik und
wertvorstellungen aber in allen
bereichen geht es um das gespräch sei es
ein politisches gespräch zwischen den
bürgern und ihren politischen vertretern
oder eine diskussion mit unseren kindern
beim abendessen
das muss unser denken bestimmen diese
krise muss so viel raum in unserem leben
belegen wie ihr gebührt es braucht die
technologie ist braucht die ökonomie es
braucht die politik ist braucht uns alle
und es braucht die geschichten und bei
den geschichten fällt ja auch auf dass
die geschichten auch figuren brauchen
sie machen sehr deutlich in dem buch
auch dass es im grunde genommen manchmal
sehr darauf ankommt welche figur sich
für die geschichte ereignet um sie
führen eine person ein die ich nicht
gekannt habe nämlich eine claudette
colvin oder kurve ich weiß gar nicht wie
man den namen ausspricht
ich konnte sie nicht aber ich kenne rosa
parks jeder kennt rosa parks die in
montgomery alabama 1955 aufgestanden ist
oder sich eben nicht erhoben hat im bus
und nicht platz gemacht habt für einen
weißen mann und damit eigentlich die
bürgerrechtsbewegung losgetreten hat sie
sagen moment es gibt eine andere
geschichte erzählen sie vielleicht mal
kurz die andere geschichte die eben
nicht so wie sie sagten war da diese
junge frau namens claudette colvin rund
neun monate bevor rosa parks ihren platz
im bus nicht freigab tat claudette etwas
ähnliches sie weigerte sich aus dem
gleichen grund in den hinteren teil des
busses zu gehen doch die
bürgerrechtsorganisation ende blazy fand
sie sei nicht die beste sprecherin die
beste erzählerin oder heldin der
geschichte zu diesem zeitpunkt denn sie
war 15 jahre alt schwanger von einem
fach
hartmann und sie entstammte einer wie es
hieß schlechten familie rosa parks
hingegen war eine aktive
bürgerrechtlerin und eine sehr kluge
strategin unter anderem erkannte sie
dass geschichte sowohl war als auch
konstruiert und kreiert ist es ist kein
zufall dass so viele gute stories
geschichte schreiben und so viele
ikonische bilder und figuren eine
historische dimension bekommen
[Musik]
im buch machte ich ein
gedankenexperiment das halt witzig und
halb wahr ist hätte sich das christentum
derart ausgebreitet wenn jesus nicht
gekreuzigt sondern in einer badewanne
ertränkt worden wäre würden seine
anhänger jetzt badewannen um den hals
tragen wären eine level nine eleven wenn
sich die türme des world trade centers
nicht so leicht zeichnen wäre hitler auf
hitler ohne seinen schnurrbart wäre dann
die auch gandhi ohne lendenschurz barack
obama änderte seinen vornamen von barry
zu barack denken sie perry obama wäre
präsident geworden
klingt so viel komischer und heroischer
ich weiß nicht aber beim klimawandel ist
es offensichtlich wir brauchen ikonische
figuren und eine solche figur ist ja
vielleicht greenberg so wird es auf
jeden fall sehr oft gesagt das heißt
sehr oft greenberg hat das potenzial
eine bewegung loszutreten weil sie ein
mädchen ist ich meine mittlerweile ist
ja eigentlich eine erwachsene frau
es wird auch immer wieder gesagt na ja
sie hat aus berga
das heißt hier ist eigentlich selber von
einer verletzlichen gruppe von menschen
das macht sie vielleicht auch besonders
glaubwürdig auf der anderen seite hat
sie gerade kürzlich wieder am world
economic forum in davos gesagt alle
hören mir zu keiner tut was das stimmt
so natürlich nicht es gehen viele auf
die straße sich trotzdem frustriert dass
sie denkt ich hab doch eine geschichte
ich erzähle euch doch was um trotzdem
passiert zu wenig
und ich denke sie unterschätzt ihren
einfluss sie hat recht und unrecht
recht hat sie indem sie sagt was sie
sagt sie hat insofern recht als sie
millionen menschen mobilisiert hat
dutzende wenig sogar hunderte millionen
ohne sie gäbe es keine
freitagsdemonstrationen in davos hätten
sie nicht so viel darüber geredet auch
wenn sie nur mist von sich gaben aber
ohne sie wäre die thematik vermutlich
gar nicht zur sprache gekommen und auch
wir zwei würden wohl jetzt nicht hier
sitzen die einfluss ist also weit
reichend aber sie hat recht insofern als
das risiko besteht dass es um gefühle
anstatt handlungen geht
manche leute schauen videos von greta
team berg sie weinen fühlen sich
hoffnungsvoll und inspiriert was ob das
schon bedeuten würde umweltaktivistin
oder aktives zu sagen anstatt dass sie
ihr leben ändern wie das trainerteam
berg getan hat und während greta eine
art heldin ist für uns unser erster
helden der klimakrise könnte man sagen
haben wir auch unseren ersten realen
bösewicht in donald trump ich arbeitete
für hillary clinton und wollte dass sie
gewinnt aber es gibt einen etwas
abartigen grund warum ich dankbar bin
dass donald trump nun präsident ist
er hat uns zur selbstreflexion gezwungen
er verkörpert das was wir nicht wollen
das was wir befürchten
und ich denke er konnte womöglich so
viele menschen wie greta mobilisieren
vor allem jugendliche die sagen das maß
ist voll wir müssen die welt ändern
dafür sind sie beschreiben die sich
anstecken lassen von einer geschichte
mit dem bild einer welle wir kennen
diese wellen in sportstadien
mit einer welle menschen machen eine
welle das reißt einen mit und sie sagen
dazu im buch etwas das mich was mich
wirklich berührt hat einen großartigen
satz sagen nämlich noch nie hat mich
eine welle zufällig in dem moment
erreicht dass die begeisterung mich
packte wellen brauchen kein gefühl sie
bringen es hervor
und das gefällt mir sehr leid ich denke
genauso ist dass man sitzt da und man
ist gleich gar nicht begeistert aber die
welle reißt einen mit und dann haben wir
ja eigentlich so eine hohe frage wer
trägt denn die welle los wir müssen
jemanden finden oder stoffe finden die
die welle lostreten
sind diese wellen solche overview
momente oder figuren beides zusammen
oder haben sie noch andere ideen
ich denke nicht dass nur etwas so eine
welle auslöste
zuerst möchte ich sagen sie ist bereits
angerollt wenn man in der welle drin
steckt kann es schwierig sein sie zu
spüren wie der witz von zwei fischen die
sich eines tages begegnen sagt der eine
das wasser ist sehr warm und der andere
was zum teufel ist wasser wenn wir in
etwas drin stecken merken wir es
manchmal kaum
die welt hat sich so stark verändert im
letzten jahr unsere wahrnehmung des
klimawandels unsere bereitschaft und
unser verlangen darüber zu reden und
unsere bereitschaft und unser verlangen
unser leben deswegen zu ändern hätte
mich jemand vor einem jahr gefragt
glauben sie dass am galadiner der golden
globes ein rein veganes menü serviert
würde hätte ich gesagt natürlich nicht
warum glauben sie der beste
hauptdarsteller ruft auf der bühne dazu
auf man solle die umwelt zuliebe weniger
fleisch essen wie das working phoenix
tat hätte ich gesagt natürlich nicht auf
die frage denken sie dass beyond mit das
erfolgreichste unternehmen in den usa
sein würde hätte ich gesagt natürlich
nicht jemand gesagt ein elektroauto
unternehmen würde zum erfolgreichsten
und größten autohersteller in der us
geschichte hätte ich mir das nie
vorstellen können
jetzt sind diese dinge
selbstverständlich und die veränderungen
erfolgen immer schneller
das ist denke ich nicht einem ereignis
oder ein
personen zuzuschreiben es stimmt schon
es verändert sich viel wobei ich
manchmal den eindruck habe ich lebe auch
in einer in einer bombe in meinem umfeld
ist es für die meisten menschen ein
thema sich zu überlegen was sie essen
oder zu versuchen weniger zu fliegen
wenn man in einer stadt wie zürich lebt
braucht man schlicht kein auto ich habe
noch nie ein auto besessen und das geht
ganz viel in meiner umgebung so und
trotzdem hat man den eindruck man tut
irgendwie zu wenig und zugleich merkt
man immer wieder das ist genau wie sie
es beschreiben verstehen ist das eine
sich motiviert fühlen und wirklich ins
handeln kommen ist das andere und das
ist ja ein philosophisches problem was
zb schon da wie die jugend beschrieben
hat der gesagt habe es widerspricht
eigentlich den verstand nicht lieber
keinen kleinen schnitt im finger zu
haben als zu verhindern dass irgendwo
ein haus zusammenkracht
und das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig
frustrierend zu merken das was wir
denken ist eigentlich doch was ganz
anderes wie das was ihr tun da gibt es
einen großen unterschied
und dass zwischen den ist das mitgefühl
das wirklich dass das fügen also ich die
frage letztendlich wie kreieren wir
diese gefühle
das fand ich lustig dass sie das sagen
denn ich habe wirklich meinen finger
verletzt ziemlich böse gestern es wollte
nicht aufhören zu bluten
und es stimmt ich konnte an nichts
anderes mehr denken ich war besessen
davon und rief meine freunde an wo gott
mein finger tut so weh das ist sie
schwierig die dinge im richtigen
verhältnis und aus die richtigen
perspektive zu sehen
aber vielleicht können wir einfach
anerkennen dass das zum menschsein
gehört und wege finden damit umzugehen
anstatt so zu tun als ob es nicht so
wenn sie in einen laden gehen und etwas
sehen dass ihnen gefällt erwägen sie es
zu stehlen kates ohrringe oder zahlen
sie immer da für sie bezahlen dafür klar
ich auch wie entscheiden sie nicht zu
stehlen müssen sie sich an den
sozialvertrag erinnern
den ladenbesitzer besonders sympathisch
finden warum stehen sie nicht was
hindert sie daran
wahrscheinlich wollen sie darauf hinaus
das ist ein automatismus ist oder ich
überlege mir das ja gar nicht sie
überlegen sich das nicht weil sie keine
person sind die stiehlt sie tun so etwas
einfach nicht vielleicht ein wenig wegen
des gesetzes aber das ist nicht die
ganze erklärung
es hat vielleicht mit ihrer erziehung zu
tun damit wie sie sich sehen wollen
aber es ist eine bewusste entscheidung
sie tun es einfach nicht entsprechend
müssen wir menschen werden die unseren
planeten nicht bestehen und die zukunft
nicht besteht
die sagt wir sind tiere die keine tiere
der gleichen spezies essen essen nämlich
keine menschen
vielleicht könnte man dieses fleisch
also zu bereiten dass es uns schmecken
würde dass es auch nicht krank macht
aber wir tun das nicht das gehört nicht
zu der art und weise wie wir leben und
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe würden sie
sagen wir müssen lernen um so zu
verändern dass wir gewisse dinge einfach
nicht mehr tun
ja ja und wir haben diesbezüglich eine
lange geschichte wir essen übrigens auch
keine hunde und keine koalas sie alle
kennen diese bilder aus australien von
toten koalas am straßenrand da reagieren
die leute so entsetzt wie konnte die
menschheit das nur zu lassen
dabei vergessen sie dass wir jedes jahr
50 milliarden tiere töten und dass dies
zu einem großen teil den tod dieses
koalas am straßenrand verursacht hat
dafür halten wir keine sklaven aber
früher taten wir dass wir behandeln
frauen nicht anders als männer
wir versuchen es zumindest das ist eine
unserer momentanen reisen
aber wenn wir die ganze
menschheitsgeschichte betrachten gibt es
viele dinge die wir zu tun pflegten und
dann erfolgte eine art moralische
revolution und wie lange es auch dauert
wie mühsam es ist und wie schwer
vorstellbar bis es soweit ist kann
ist die revolution da schauen wir zurück
und fragen uns wie konnten wir je so
sein wie konnten wir das hier tun
es gibt ja auch personen die sagen es
braucht vielleicht gar nicht so sehr
eine veränderung von uns wir haben ja
auch die technik wir können eine
technologische lösung machen es gibt die
unterschiedlichsten vorstellungen wie
der klimawandel gebremst werden kann
einer der zu meinem großen erstaunen bei
uns in der sendung für technologische
lösungen plädiert hat ist al gore und er
war bei ich post zu gast wir hören in
ganz kurz zu dieser art von
exponentielle veränderungen die wir
kennen das aus dem bereich der
technologie mit den burschen gesetz
mobiltelefonen und vielen anderen
geräten
es ist sehr spannend dass dieses gleiche
muster jetzt bei erneuerbaren energien
auftaucht bei der led beleuchtung bei
elektrofahrzeugen batterien bei
tausenden neuen technologien
die welt befindet sich gerade im frühen
stadium einer globalen
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution ermöglicht
durch digitale werkzeuge wie die
künstliche intelligenz das internet der
dinge
sie hat den umfang der industriellen
revolution aber mit der geschwindigkeit
der digitalen revolution
sie ist eine realität in unserem leben
und wir sollten sie als basis für echte
hoffnung wahrnehmen
wir können das lösen wir werden es lösen
al gore ist veganer aus ökologischen
gründen ersetzt also seine hoffnung
nicht nur in technologische lösungen
er macht auch als individuum die nötigen
schritte bis die technologie so weit ist
das würde ich also als gute balance
bezeichnen etwas hatte jedoch nicht
erwähnt dass die industrielle und die
digitale revolution antrieb war das geld
es ging nur ums geld das war der einzige
anreiz für unternehmen innovation
voranzutreiben
das kann jetzt nicht mehr der einzige
antrieb für innovationen seien grüne
technologien werden lukrativ sein und
menschen werden tonnenweise geld machen
durch ihre mit beteiligung
die lösung der klimakrise aber als
ganzes gesehen macht es wenig sinn als
geschäftsmodell und die leute die über
mögliche technologische lösungen für
dieses problem sprechen wird man nur
sagen deshalb sollten wir zwei millionen
dollar in staatlich unterstützte
forschung stecken oder deshalb sollten
wir den steuersatz um zehn prozent
erhöhen bis wir die klimakrise gelöst
haben
niemand ist gewählt in diese nötigen
ideen zu investieren sondern präsentiert
andere lösungen um der harten arbeit aus
dem weg zu gehen
skeptisch vielleicht kann ja auch noch
wirklich über den begriff der hoffnung
sprechen und zu diesem gefühl
zurückkehren das uns befallen kann wenn
wir über die klimakrise nachdenken
sie sagen im buch es gibt eigentlich
nichts was sie zugleich so hoffnungsfroh
und zur hoffnungslos macht wie der
klimawandel und sie haben diese
geschichte erzählt von diesem mädchen
das sie gefragt hat ob sie glauben dass
es noch lösen können und dass man selber
gesagt hat vielleicht nicht rechtzeitig
haben sie tage an dem sind sie
verzweifelt und tage das in die voller
hoffnung oder ist das immer
gleichzeitigen ihnen drehen dieses
gefühl es geht auf und ab
ich lese zb in einem artikel dass wir
die menge des methan ausstoßes in die
atmosphäre unterschätzt haben
das verschlägt mir den atem und ich bin
irgendwie verzweifelt
auch wenn ich trank sprechen höre dann
gibt es andere dinge die mich sehr
hoffnungsvoll stimmen
in meiner familie ist es fast ein witz
dass ich oft meine kinder zurufe und
sage jungs ich glaube wir lösen dieses
problem das letzte mal als ich das zu
ihnen sagte war der auslöser die
starköchin seminos rat die in den usa
sehr berühmt ist
sie hat ihre eigene show auf netflix
namens salz fettsäure hitze und ist eine
einflussreiche persönlichkeit in den usa
die last dieses buch und verkündete sie
würde zum frühstück und mittagessen
keine tierischen produkte messen
ich dachte wow wenn chefköche das zu
thematisieren beginnen wenn restaurants
anfangen ihr fleisch angebot zu
reduzieren
und wenn sie darüber hinaus auch noch
sagen warum bekommst du den eindruck das
könnte sehr schnell ein starkes echo
auslösen
das gleiche fühlte ich als ich sah wie
an den golden globes die stars darüber
sprachen
ich denke es ist nur eine frage der zeit
bis leute wie michelle obama im
fernsehen auftreten und sagen unsere
familie wird den fleischkonsum
reduzieren
denn wir vertrauen der wissenschaft und
wissen was sie uns sagt wenn solche
dinge passieren fühle ich mich sehr
hoffnungsvoll aber es gibt andere
momente da möchte ich meinen kindern
nicht in die augen schauen müssen weil
ich so sicher bin dass wir ihre welt
ruinieren sehr deprimiert hat im letzten
jahr war ein beitrag von chancen fanden
einen anderen us amerikanischen
schriftsteller dem new yorker
geschrieben hat wir sollten mal aufhören
so zu tun als gäbe es die katastrophe
noch irgendwie abzuwenden
und es gibt einen anderen beitrag den
sie oft zitieren nämlich von reus kranz
in new york sein ist er ein weiterer
geschrieben hat mit dem titel learning
hat zudem die anthropozän wir auch sagt
das größte problem angesichts des
klimawandels eigentlich ein
philosophisches nämlich wie wir jetzt
lernen zu sterben und wie wir aus
sterbliche auf diese katastrophe blicken
diese beiträge sind es bei denen ich
denke da muss man aufpassen dass man
nicht in eine lethargie kippt es gibt
zwei arten solche standpunkte zu
betrachten und ich möchte vorausschicken
beide sind wunderbare autoren und denke
aber man könnte einwenden es sei nicht
gerade hilfreich zu sagen wir sind
verloren
das ist aber nicht meine kritik meine
kritik ist es stimmt nicht die stärkste
reaktion auf jonathan franzens essay kam
von wissenschaftlern
sie sagten es stimmt einfach recht die
informationen die er zitierte war aus
dem zusammenhang
wissen und fehlinterpretiert haben schon
vorher sagte es stimmt nicht dass wir
verloren sind es stimmt auch nicht dass
wir den planeten retten werden die
wahrheit ist wir werden viele dinge
verlieren und das ausmass des verlusts
hängt nur von unserem handeln
seit der industriellen revolution wurden
100 prozent der globalen erwärmung durch
menschliche aktivitäten verursacht so
ist auch alles was jetzt passiert das
resultat menschlicher aktivitäten
jonathan franzen hat recht wir sind
daran gewisse dinge zu verlieren die wir
nicht mehr retten können
ein paar küstenstädte womöglich die
korallenriffe ein paar prozent des
schelfeises wir werden viele tierarten
und viele menschen leben verlieren das
heißt aber nicht dass wir verloren sind
eine weile lang hatte ich den eindruck
diese apokalypsen rhetorik dient dazu
eine welle loszutreten leute denken wir
müssen etwas tun und sie es steht ein
aktivismus im moment habe ich das gefühl
es entsteht das gegenteil leute
reagieren so dass sie in eine so enge
lingus haltung kommen dass sie denken
auch wir gehen sowieso unter spielt ja
eh keine rolle mehr
und manchmal wird dann auch darauf
verwiesen und sie tun das auch dass man
sagt es gab ja schon fünf massensterben
vor uns schon ganz oft ist die welt
sozusagen untergegangen und es war
eigentlich immer eine klimakatastrophe
außer bei den dinosauriern da ist
wahrscheinlich ein meteoriteneinschlag
dafür verantwortlich gewesen dass sie
muss aber ausgestorben sind
der unterschied ist einfach dass wir
jetzt in einer zeit leben in dem der
klimawandel menschengemacht ist
was genau bedeutet dieser unterschied
philosophisch oder intellektuell der
minister
das bedeutet dass wir uns selbst in
diese situation hineinmanövriert haben
wir sind ihr nicht zufällig ausgeliefert
sie ist nicht etwas ungerechtes sie ist
auch nicht einfach pech sie ist die
logische folge unseres handelns es vor
relativ kurzer zeit sagen wir bis vor 30
oder 20 vielleicht sogar bis vor zehn
jahren konnte der durchschnittliche
mensch auf unkenntnis plädieren wir
konnten sagen wir wussten
was wir mit unseren tun verursachen wir
wussten nicht dass wir so viel
zerstörung hervorrufen
die ursache wirkungs kette war nicht
sichtbar für uns aber darauf kann heute
nur plädieren die usa legen hinter
europa was das klimabewusstsein betrifft
etwa 91 prozent der us bürgerinnen und
bürger sagen sie akzeptieren den
klimawandel als wissenschaftliche
tatsache 91 prozent es gibt in den usa
doppelt so viele menschen die an die
existenz des fabelwesens bigfoot glauben
als menschen die den klimawandel leugnen
70 prozent der us bevölkerung wünschen
die usa wären im pariser klimaabkommen
geblieben eingeschlossen die mehrheit
der republikaner
oft heißt es das sei ein konflikt
zwischen links liberalen und
konservativen oder zwischen städtischen
und ländlichen gebieten zwischen
religiösen und säkularen drohten
zwischen alt und jung
das stimmt nicht es geht hier um die
grundwerte von uns allen
und nun sind wir am punkt an dem wir
nicht mehr auf unkenntnis plädieren
können wir wissen was passiert und
unsere entscheidung man könnte sogar
sagen unsere menschlichkeit wird
offenbar die frage ist sind wir als
spezies fähig nein zu sagen zu dingen
die wir wollen wie fliegen bei fleisch
essen usw zu gunsten von etwas anderem
dass wir wollen die verantwortung die
auf der freiheit der wächst es ist
unsere wahl haben sie wie wir uns
entscheiden wie wir weitermachen
sie erzählen auch an einer gewissen
stelle die geschichte von jan karski der
1942 aus cattolica in polen im
warschauer ghetto beobachtet hat wie das
ghetto geschlossen wurde wie die
menschen im vernichtungslager gebracht
wo das ghetto in ein vernichtungslager
umgewandelt wurde
und er geht in die usa geflüchtet und
erzählt diese geschichte einem sehr
einflussreichen anwalt um dem wird nicht
geglaubt
es wurde ein bisschen der vorwurf
gemacht dass sie diese situation jetzt
angesichts des klimawandels vergleichen
würden mit holocaust lüge
ich weiß gar nicht ob sie diese
parallele so ziehen wollten
aber vielleicht können sie etwas dazu
sagen wie sehr gleichen sich diese
situationen denn wirklich
diese parallele wollte ich nicht sehen
wie sie erwähnten schrieb ich einen
großen teil des buchs als meine
großmutter im sterben und sie hat wie
ich sagte als einziges mitglied ihrer
familie den krieg überlebt sie überlebte
weil sie sich zur flucht entschied ihre
schwestern beschlossen zu bleiben
eltern großeltern ihre cousins freunde
alle anderen beschlossen zu bleiben
nicht weil sie holocaust leugner waren
sie wussten dass die deutschen kommen
würden
sie glaubten nicht dass das was kommen
würde so anders sein würde als das was
zuvor passiert war
meine großmutter war nicht klüger als
sisi war kein besserer mensch und sie
hatte auch nicht mehr angst zu sterben
sie konnte nicht mal den unterschied
zwischen ihr und den anderen erklären
darüber musste ich oft nach dem denn ich
bin eigentlich eine art leuschner
natürlich an erkenne ich die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse ich weiß
was geschieht aber etwas in mir drin
glaubt dennoch nicht dass das wirklich
passiert denn wenn ich es glaubte würde
ich ein ganz anderes leben führen
ich würde mich nur darauf fokussieren
ich würde meine persönlichen vorsätze
nie in frage stellt
womöglich wäre ich gar nicht hierher
geflogen wissen sie doch noch mal ein
unterschieden die erzählen ja beide
perspektiven ob jemand bleibt und
getötet wird und die gefahr die da kommt
vielleicht nicht richtig einschätzt oder
auch gar nicht weiß was tun oder ob die
andere person die sie erwähnen nicht
eben diese person die die nicht glaubt
dieser felix frankfurter heißt er der
sozusagen in wird ja die geschichte
erzählt und die schwierigkeit ist dass
das dass wir ja sehr oft in dieser
situation sehen wer sich da nicht so
dass wir nichts tun könnten sondern die
geschichte wird uns erzählt und trotzdem
reagieren wir nicht und da hatte ich
schon den eindruck ist eine spezielle
form von unrechts das sie an
ich erzähle die geschichte ganz kurz
damit die zuschauer im bild sind der 28
jährige jan karski katholik ein
unglaublich heldenhafter mensch
schmuggelte sich ins warschauer ghetto
und sogar in ein vernichtungslager um
beweismittel und zeugenaussagen zu
sammeln
die wollte er in den westen bringen und
damit die usa und england überzeugen in
den krieg einzugreifen und die deutschen
zu stoppen als er in die usa kam traf er
den verfassungsrichter felix frankfurter
einen der klügsten köpfe welche die usa
je hatten
er war zudem jude was wichtig ist für
die geschichte jan karski gab ihm alle
beweis hatte das passiert dort das sagen
diese menschen da sind bilder von
frankfurter stellte ihm eine reihe von
fragen dann sagte er ich will ehrlich
sein ich kann nicht glauben was sie mir
erzählen
jan karski fragte warum sollte ich nur
warum in aller welt sollte ich sie
anbieten frankfurter erwiderte ich sagte
nicht dass sie lügen ich sagte ich kann
ihnen nicht glauben
und dann gab er ein schönes bekenntnis
sei ein herz und verstand sind so
beschaffen dass ich ihnen nicht glauben
kann
es kann sein dass unser herz und
verstand so beschaffen sind dass wir
nicht glauben können was uns die
wissenschaftler sagen wir denken nicht
dass sie lügen
wir glauben auch nicht an eine andere
wissenschaftliche wahrheit wir können es
einfach nicht derart in unser leben
integrieren dass wir angemessen darauf
reagieren
deshalb sind wir nicht schlechter oder
ignorante menschen
es gehört vielleicht einfach zum
menschsein es ist aber auch nicht das
ende der geschichte denn es gibt wege
diesen fehlenden glauben zu überwinden
indem sie uns zum beispiel routinen und
gewohnheiten aneignen
da müssen sie nicht jedes mal überlegen
wie sie ihre ferien verbringen oder als
sie im restaurant essen sollen sie
müssen nicht jedes mal entsprechende
gefühle und gedanken abrufen
es ist eher wie im laden muss
entscheiden nicht zu stehlen
sie sind einfach nicht eine person die
stiehlt
vielleicht auch mit dieser untergangs
rhetorik umzugehen sich einfach mal zu
überlegen was verloren wir denn
eigentlich wenn es uns menschen nicht
mehr geben würde und es gibt diese
passage in ihrem buch das finde ich von
den von den schönsten passagen überhaupt
nur sie einfach wahllos aufzählen was
der mensch so tut und was es nicht mehr
geben würde sie haben eine wunderbare
listig nennen ein paar sachen wörter
lernen zusammen aussehens elf posten
eifersucht runterschlucken landkarten
mühevoll zusammenfalten verlobungsringe
aussuchen temperatur von milch am
handgelenk prüfen grottige lobreden
zerknüllen eine ganze liste und ich habe
die mit großem vergnügen gelesen und
habe zunehmend den eindruck vielleicht
ist das wir müssen uns wieder erzählen
zu welcher zärtlichkeit wir fähig sind
zu welcher originalität wir fähig sind
was sie auch großes vermögen das sie
nicht nur zerstörungswut jungs tragen
sondern ganz wunderbare dinge tun können
dem stimme ich zu
aber wir können nicht unseren alltag
leben und ständig daran denken wir zwei
können ein gespräch führen einander
wirklich überzeugen und uns davon sehr
berühren lassen
wir gehen auseinander und sagen ich
werde mein leben ändern ich bin bereit
zur lösung dieses problems beizutragen
und wir meinen das ihr ernst womöglich
weinen wir sogar so ernst ist es uns und
zwei stunden später geht das leben
weiter sie müssen zu einem meeting
hetzen und ich muss zum hotel zurück und
denke es ist schon spät was soll ich
essen hier gibt es nichts rechtlich was
soll dieses eine mal esse ich etwas das
ich eigentlich nicht essen sollte ich
zurück nach new york und natürlich
besteige ich nicht ein schiff sondern
ich fliege unsere lebensumstände und was
es alles braucht und durch den tag zu
navigieren nehmen uns komplett in
beschlag darüber schwinden unsere
vorsätze und wir sind geneigt uns das
leben leichter und angenehmer zu machen
dabei vergessen wir das andere es kommt
also durchaus vor dass wir ergriffen
sind wenn ich bilder von
überschwemmungen buschbränden
sturmfluten und klimaflüchtlingen sehe
bewegt nicht das zutiefst
dann frage ich keine sekunde was zu tun
ist
das problem ist ich sehe mir diese
bilder nicht ständig an
meistens schaue ich auf mein handy lese
die zeitung oder bin unterwegs und
absorbiert von der hektik des alltags
dabei geht das andere vergessen das
gespräch zu beenden dass man denkt es
gibt doch diese wunderbaren dinge über
die wir uns unterhalten können jetzt
haben sie sozusagen die welle wieder
bisschen gestoppt es tut mir leid
nein es ist doch die frage auch der
ehrlichkeit womit enden wir eigentlich
oder ich weiß es nicht vielleicht ist
das ehrlichste zu sagen es gibt eben
wirklich beides hoffnung und
verzweiflung
ich denke besser als über hoffnung und
verzweiflung zu sanieren ist sehr
konkret und sachlich über unsere
vorsätze zu reden
ich hatte eine lesung in brüssel vor
etwa drei monaten in der anschließenden
signierstunde kam ein junges paar und
schneide vielleicht 20 jahre alt sie
leben das buch vor mich hin und
blätterten zur seite wo ich jeweils
signieren und da war alles voll
geschrieben
ich fragte was ist das sie sagten wir
heiraten in ein paar monaten und
geschlossen heute abend dass wir einen
plan brauchen wie wir unser leben
gestalten
wenn wir keinen plan haben tun wir was
wir gewohnt sind wie alle anderen auch
ihr plan war nicht mehr als zwei kinder
zu haben vegetarisch zu essen außer sie
sind bei freunden zu gast und es gibt
nur fleisch zwei tage pro woche vegan zu
essen und stadt ein auto nur carsharing
nicht mehr als 1500 kilometer pro jahr
und anstatt der üblichen signatur
wollten sie dass sich als zeuge
unterschreibt das fand die charmant und
schön
doch dann schämte ich nicht denn ich
realisierte obwohl ich dieses buch
geschrieben auf der bühne daraus gelesen
und es signiert habe hatte ich selber
keinen plan
ich erwartete dass unsere regierung und
die konzerne einen plan haben was
wartete ich sogar von der schule die
meine kinder besuchen
aber ich hatte keinen plan also ging ich
in mein hotel zurück und setzte einen
plan auf dazu gehörte 2020 keine flug
urlaube zu machen hätten sie mich bevor
ich das auf schrieb gefragt was tun sie
gegen das problem der flugreisen hätte
ich gesagt ich versuche weniger zu
fliegen was gar nichts bedeutet
sobald es aber notiert ist mit zahlen
und daten und die einen zeugen hast
verändert dass dein leben
ich mache mir also weniger gedanken
bezüglich hoffnung oder
hoffnungslosigkeit sondern darüber wie
wir diese gefühle konkretisieren können
damit wir uns nicht nur auf sie stürzen
müssen einen plan machen entschlüsse
fassen das ganze auf schreiben uns unter
beihilfe eines zeugens unterschreiten
sie könnten das jetzt gerade vor der
kamera touren dann sehen ihnen alle
dabei zu aber keine angst ich bringe sie
nicht in verlegenheit
auch ihnen danke fürs interesse wer
weiter lesen möchte in einem
handsignierten buch unseres gastes
schreibt eine mail an philosophie az.ch
wir verlosen je ein exemplar von wir
sind das klima und tiere essen
philosophie gibt es wieder in einer
woche ich post spricht mit katajun
amirpur über den iran und
eurozentristisch es denken eine gute
zeit bis bald
[Musik]